well the academic research in writing
this is distinct although distinct from
it related to the to the judging so so
my academic work continues to be
primarily focused on the economic
perspective on issues of law primarily
but related issues of public politics
I've written about aging and about
sexuality and these are topics where I
think there is a neglected economic
angle but I I'm I'm eclectic and I have
brought to bear sociology and philosophy
and other history and so on other areas
so so that's that's the academic but as
far as being a judge is concerned we
don't choose our cases so just take them
as they come and I've been where I've
seen an opportunities economics in
judging I have certainly taken that
opportunity but more important really
than that my dissatisfaction with this
moralistic traditional moralistic
vocabulary of law continues and I'm
disturbed by the degree to which the
lawyers arguing cases to us present them
in terms of this traditional vocabulary
without focusing us on on the facts on
practical considerations cluding
economic not
the pragmatist is someone who thinks
that the consequences of a proposed
course of action are the critical factor
in deciding whether you want to follow
that course and in a unit in a judicial
case they're always you know two sides
plaintiff and defendant one is going to
win each is advocating a course of
action which will have consequences good
or bad and I'd like to get the lawyers
to focus and I like my own response to a
case to focus on what those consequences
are well a lot of the time it's just
intuitive we're not given enough facts
to make a you know rigorous cost-benefit
analysis but but often one feels at
least a confidence in one's intuition
that if the parties that if you can
figure out concretely what will happen
if one side or the other if one position
of the other becomes the rule of law to
govern future cases we have won has
confidence in that outcome then one
feels one is making a pragmatically
sound
well judges don't look back actually I
any judge who's realistic will realize
that a significant percentage of the
votes he's made in cases are either
indeterminate as to whether they're
right or wrong whether they're wrong
so I've I've I've said and more than an
approximately 6,000 Appeals in my 26
years as a judge now I know there's a
percentage of those cases which which I
which I which I voted incorrectly but I
have no inclination to look back try to
figure out which than which they were
now sometimes in a new case people
parties will advocate a position that is
contrary to one I took in a previous
case I'm happy to re-examine my earlier
position but I don't sort of
independently in the absence of
challenged look back and try to figure
out what's right or wrong the other
thing it so I've written sighs they ever
heard more than 6,000 cases I've written
almost 2,500 opinions I forgotten most
of them right I don't carry 2,500
opinions in my head but if I'm reminded
about a case as I say I'm happy to
you